- [Marc] Hello and welcome, everyone.
Good morning, welcome to re:Invent.
My name is Mark, I'm an engineer.
I work in DSQL, and I'm
joined by my colleague Raluca.
She's a database engineer.
She works in DSQL with me.
And this is a code talk. This
is a developer's perspective.
We're gonna be building
a very simple application
in DSQL this morning, using Lambda.
And I'm gonna show you
how to connect to DSQL,
how to use the CDK
to manage your
infrastructure declaratively.
We're gonna to be writing
some banking applications,
just very simple application.
You know, turns out I owe Raluca money,
so I need to settle my debts with her.
(Raluca chuckles)
And we're gonna be showing you
how to scale that application up,
how to deal with concurrency,
what happens when there's
conflicts in the application.
This is really meant to
be a bit of a baking show.
And so there're gonna be
moments where, you know,
the pie is in the oven.
We're gonna be waiting for it,
so feel free to ask us questions.
Yeah, let's get into it.
- [Raluca] All right,
I'm gonna take over Marc's computer.
- [Marc] Okay.
- [Raluca] It's part of
his paying his debts to me.
- [Marc] So a quick show of
hands, who here has used DSQL?
Okay, that's about what I expected.
So, DSQL was announced at
re:Invent this time last year
in preview, almost exactly a year ago,
and became generally
available earlier this year.
We're about six months
old now. So, what is DSQL?
DSQL is a distributed
implementation of Postgres.
And so, for the longest time,
customers have been asking us,
"Hey, we really like relational databases.
We like being able to do
joins, manage our schema,
run complex queries,
but we also like systems like DynamoDB,
where there is no single point of failure,
where the system scales horizontally.
And we also like services like Lambda,
where I don't have to
think about infrastructure,
or scaling, or patching, or
security, or anything like that.
So these three things, I
want them in one package,
and that's what we set out to
do, and that's what DSQL is.
DSQL has four pillars.
You can find these in our website:
virtually unlimited
scale, high availability,
no infrastructure
management, and ease of use.
Okay, let's hop on over
to the DSQL console
and create a cluster.
This is gonna go by really fast.
I challenge you all to count to 10.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
- [Raluca] I was late.
- [Marc] I can't count to 10?
- (chuckles) Done.
- There we go. Okay, great.
So, that's what it looks like
to create a DSQL cluster.
It's pretty fast.
We've just rolled out
fast practice creation
about two weeks ago.
Let's do that in slowmo.
So Raluca, take us back on over.
You'll notice that there's
actually two options there
in the dropdown, there's
single-region or multi-region.
For today's talk,
we're gonna be focusing
on single-region clusters.
There is no scroll bar on the screen.
This is something that I'm
just like super excited about
because, you know, I've
made a ton of databases
in my career, and every time I make one,
I find it just like really awful
because I have to make all
these decisions ahead of time.
It's really hard to decide
what instance type do I want,
how many replicas, what
subnet should I be in,
what security?
It's just this endless list of choices,
and they all really matter.
And so which one of
those is gonna be the one
that causes an outage
and makes me wake up in
the middle of the night.
And in DC recall,
you don't have to worry
about any of that stuff.
You can tag your cluster if you want.
If you wanna change the tags
later, go ahead and do that.
Clusters are always encrypted by default.
If you wanna change to a different key,
you can do that here.
If you wanna change your mind later
and move to a different
key, you can do that later.
You can toggle deletion protection
and we've recently rolled out
some advanced security options
for some of our customers.
But that's really all there is to it.
Let's connect to DSQL cluster, Raluca.
- [Raluca] Right on.
Let's choose this one. Have
you done anything with it?
- Nope, not yet.
- Okay.
- [Marc] Okay, so we have two ways
to connect the DSQL cluster.
This is the query editor.
We actually only shipped
this about two weeks ago
and this is just a Postgres editor
running in the web browser, right?
What's really cool about this editor
is that your browser is
connecting to DSQL directly.
DSQL supports web sockets.
And so, your browser's
just connecting over
and speaking the Postgres
protocol right there.
We also have a CloudShell integration.
So, every page in the AWS console
has a little shell at the bottom left.
I don't know if you've all seen that.
But you can also go to any DSQL cluster
and click Connect with CloudShell.
It will just fill in the
prompt with everything
that's needed to connect.
Okay, so that's getting started.
We're gonna swap over here,
and we're gonna start
to build an application.
- All right.
- Okay.
So before we do that,
I wanna orientate you.
So I've built a little starter
kit for this code talk.
It's on GitHub if you
would like to check it out.
We've got a link we can share
with you after the talk.
And there's a little starter kit,
and it's got two key folders.
The first one is the CDK folder
and the second one is the Lambda folder.
I'm actually gonna start
with the Lambda one
'cause it's really simple.
Here we have a function,
actually, quick show of hands,
who has built a Lambda function before?
Okay, almost all of you. Great.
Okay, so I won't go into
too much detail here.
We have a request handler.
This request handler is taking an event,
the input is gonna be a request,
one of these request interfaces
and then the response.
And so we can call this function and say,
"Hello," whatever we want,
and then it's gonna return
a classic greeting to us.
Meanwhile, in the CDK folder,
we have our Lambda
function being bundled up.
And every time we deploy the stack,
we're just gonna take the latest code
that we've been working
on, send it over to Lambda,
and then we can invoke it.
The second thing that's
happening in the starter kit
is a DSQL cluster.
And this cluster, you'll
see it just kind of follows
what you saw in the UI, right?
So, we have deletion
protection, we have our tags.
And if you're using TypeScript,
you can get this like nice
order completion to say,
"What else can I configure here?"
Now I've gone ahead and
created one of these already,
and when you run it, this is what you get.
You're gonna get two outputs.
These outputs are defined
here at the bottom
of the CDK stack.
That's, say, what our cluster endpoint is
and what the security, the
IAM role for our function is.
DSQL clusters have their own endpoint.
Actually, behind the scenes
is a big shared endpoint,
which is really important,
because that's gonna be part of
how we provide automatic
capacity management.
But we present a unique
endpoint to your cluster.
This is just basically
a UUID for your cluster,
which makes it just really easy
to connecting with Postgres clients
because they expect a host name, right?
So that's why we do it like this.
And what I wanna show you
quickly is what it looks like
to invoke our Lambda function.
See, here we say
AWS Lambda invoke with the
CLI is our function name,
and we're gonna pass in name=reinvent
and write the response to that file.
And then we can take a look
at that file, Hello reinvent.
Okay, great.
What I wanna do now is to show you
what it looks like to connect.
So we need to export a couple of variables
to make the Postgres shell work.
The first one is the PG user.
I'm gonna set that to admin.
The next one is the PG database,
which is gonna be Postgres.
Then we have PG host.
And if we try and connect,
now we're gonna get a prompt
for a password, right?
So where does my password come from?
And I'm gonna get one
from the AWS command line tool.
That's my password.
Feel free to copy it down
because you'll notice
that it's expired already.
So the way this works
is through a technique
that looks a lot like S3 pre-signed URLs,
if you're familiar with those.
So the AWS SDK, what it usually is doing
is making HTTP requests
to a service saying,
"Hey, I would like to download
this file from my S3 bucket."
And it's building an HDP
request that has headers,
it has a body, and then
the SDK is gonna go
and sign that request, right?
So it's gonna go and run these
cryptographic hash functions
of your headers and over the request body,
and it's gonna put a signature, right?
And that signature is gonna
give us a tamper proof property,
so that if anybody
intercepted your request,
they can't modify it.
It's also gonna give us expiry.
And so if somebody managed
to intercept this request,
they would have a time bound
window in which to exploit it.
And usually, you can't do that
because your request is being
sent over a TLS connection.
Something like S3 pre-signed URLs
works a little bit differently
because what you're saying is,
"I, who have access to my S3 bucket,
I'm gonna make this request,
but before I send the request,
I'm just gonna take that signed URL,
and then I'm gonna intentionally
give it to somebody else."
Right? That's pretty much
what's going on here.
You'll see that this looks like a URL.
Here's the host, it's our cluster.
We have an action called DBConnectAdmin,
and then we have that signature.
And this is gonna take
the place of our password.
So rather than giving a very,
very short-lived password,
I can just export this into
an environment variable.
(keyboard clicking)
And now we should be in. Oops!
Did I get the host wrong?
(keyboard clicking)
Ah, I remember what I didn't do.
I haven't had coffee this morning.
(Raluca chuckles)
Ah, demo.
- [Raluca] Did you send the region?
(keyboard clicking)
- [Marc] Okay, there we're in.
So I'm using a demo account,
and I forgot to switch
the profile of the shell,
but we're in now,
and we can just run kind of
standard Postgres commands.
And what I'm gonna do
is exactly the same thing
in our Lambda function.
So we're gonna go over
to this Lambda function,
and you'll notice that there's
a file here called db.ts.
And this is essentially
the node Postgres driver.
I've just gone to their readme,
and I've copy-pasted
everything into this file.
There's one change,
which is this password.
And so the password is gonna
come from calling a function.
And that function is
essentially the same thing
that we just did on the
command line, right?
This is, "Hey, use the SDK to
generate one of these tokens."
And you'll notice that the
cluster endpoint is coming in
through an environment variable.
So let's just wire this up quickly.
We're gonna say my cluster endpoint.
- [Raluca] And while you do
that, we do take questions.
So wave your hand if you
want me to grab the mic
and get a question.
Yeah, we have a question. How about that?
All right, I'll-
- [Person] Thank you.
You mentioned that you
don't need security groups
and things like that.
Does that mean DSQL runs as
just like a general service,
kind of like an S3,
you don't have it in your
VPC or something like that?
- [Raluca] So we do have public endpoints,
and we do have the option
to set up a VPC endpoint
if you need that.
- [Person] Would it be
through A VPC endpoint?
- [Raluca] But it would
be through a VPC endpoint.
Yes, correctly. Another question?
- [Person] Is there a
MySQL flavor of DSQL?
(Raluca chuckling)
No?
- Not yet.
- Not yet, okay.
- [Raluca] But we are very,
not very specific in terms of SQL dialect.
So if you have an application
that's pretty much sticking
to the general dialect,
you should be able to
use the DSQL as well.
Okay, one question,
- [Person] Just to touch
on the VPC endpoint part.
I noticed sometimes in
some newer services in AWS,
even if you do have VPC endpoints,
you don't necessarily always
support endpoint policies.
Do you support endpoint policies for DSQL?
- [Raluca] We just added
resource-based policies, yes.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Person] That's really
important for our use cases.
- [Raluca] What's the use cases?
- We don't want potential of...
We don't want the potential of,
you know, people getting
access to our VPC.
It's security requires it on our side.
I can't remember the exact details,
but there's always a
sticking point for us.
- [Raluca] Got it. Thank you.
- [Marc] Yeah, there's,
we've actually got a
really detailed blog post
on how to do this.
If you wanna chat to me afterwards,
then I can give you the link.
But it goes through like,
there are five different ways
that you can lock this down.
And as Reluca just mentioned,
and you saw on the cluster creation page,
is that advanced tick box,
you can put in just any kind of standard
AWS policy language stuff there.
So you can say, "Restrict
to these IP addresses,
restrict to these VPCs,"
anything like that.
Okay, I need to quickly update
you on what I did in this.
So we've changed our
Lambda function to say,
"Give me one of these
pools, database pools,
and that we're gonna run a query."
And so the idea
is that if we're still
able to see our greeting,
then we've connected to DSQL, right?
And I wanna quickly draw your attention
to this function here.
This is gonna make sure
that we are gonna reuse our connections
between Lambda invocations, right?
So the first time our Lambda starts up,
we're gonna have to initialize the pool.
This pool's gonna maintain 20 connections,
up to 20 connections, in the background.
Like, our Lambda function's
gonna get one request at a time,
so this is totally overkill.
But you can do kind of
whatever you wanna do here,
but every time a connection's opened,
we're gonna go grab one of
these authentication tokens.
Now this is just a really,
really fast operation.
It takes something like
20 nanoseconds to run.
And if you are using a
service like S3 or Dynamo,
you're actually running this
all the time on every request.
With DSQL, you're just running this code
once per connection.
Okay, the second thing we've done here
is we've just asked the
SDK to wire in our endpoint
into the Lambda function.
And then down here,
we've told IAM that we want
to allow this Lambda function
to connect to the database.
And if I do that and run my function,
I'm expecting it to fail.
And the reason I'm expecting it to fail
is because we've not yet told the database
to allow our functioning, right?
So we've Lambda, "Hey,
the role that you have
is allowed to connect
to this DSQL cluster,"
but the DSQL cluster is trying to see
whether our application,
which is connecting and
is a user called myapp,
is allowed to connect.
And we haven't actually set that up yet.
So let's do that quickly.
We can do "create role myapp with login."
And then I gotta do some
copy-pasting of this ARN
to say that this AWS ARN is allowed to be,
is allowed permission to
grant this, to use this role.
(keyboard clicking)
And if we try and run that again,
we should hopefully see success.
(keyboard clicking)
Okay, (claps) so the way this works,
we can actually just take a
look at this table quickly.
(keyboard clicking)
You don't have to remember these names,
I just use tab completion there.
So there's a name space
in the database called CIS
that contains all our metadata.
And you'll see that we've
got a mapping that says
this IAM role is allowed to
become this Postgres role.
And the reason we went this
direction in the DSQL design
is that it exposes the full
power of Postgres permissions.
Right, so if you wanna say,
"Here's a role that can only
like read these tables in the schema
or a role that has read, write,
or only to specific tables,"
you can do all of that
with the standard Postgres,
the standard Postgres role system.
The only thing you need
to do is sort of bind
which IAM entities are
allowed to become withdrawals.
Okay, so I'm gonna get coding
on our banking application.
But before we do that,
I wanna quickly show you
what the schema looks like.
So we can have a table called accounts.
(keyboard clicking)
And accounts have an ID
that's just an integer,
and it's a primary key.
And they're gonna have a
balance, which is an integer too.
And once we have this set up,
we can start to do a
balance transfer, right?
So we can run a transaction
where we have some money in one account,
some money in another account,
and then we can move it over.
So I'm gonna do that the wrong way,
and then we're gonna talk
about why that's wrong.
(keyboard clicking)
- [Raluca] Okay, can I start
talking about transactions?
You might not make it to the next session,
but (chuckles) as a database geek,
I really love transactions.
And the reason I prefer
to do database changes
inside the transaction
is because it allows me
to specify all the changes
to succeed or fail at once.
So you're familiar,
everything that goes between begin,
and then commit or rollback,
will succeed together or fail together.
So that's the atomicity of a transaction.
Do you wanna-
- [Marc] Yeah, so I just
did it the wrong way, right?
Because what happens if
after running this statement,
my laptop died, right?
At this point, like
what I'm intending to do
is move some money between accounts,
but any number of things
that can go wrong, right?
Like, we may lose connectivity,
database may crash,
but there also could be
business logic errors.
Like, maybe I don't have
enough money, right?
What happens if I only
have $10 to my name,
and I, you know, unfortunately,
I get into a little bit of debt?
And so I'm trying to pay
off all my debt at once.
So I'm gonna go to Reluca,
I'm gonna go to somebody else,
I'm gonna say, "Start a transaction.
How much money is in my account? $10.
Let's go and pay both debts
off at the same time," right?
And so without any kind
of consistency checks,
two transactions could start.
They could both determine that
I have enough money to pay,
we could deduct money from both accounts,
and then we're gonna land
up with a bad outcome
where I've sort of been able
to spend $20 despite only having one.
And so for these kinds of reasons,
we wanna make sure that we're
always using transactions.
DSQL supports something
that's very equivalent
to Postgres repeatable read isolation,
except it's just one
not stronger than that.
It's a strong snapshot isolation mode.
And for those of you who
aren't deeply familiar
with isolation modes,
really the easiest way to understand them
is through this concept of anomalies.
And an anomaly is something
that you can see in your transaction
that doesn't make sense, right?
So like a good example of this one
you've probably all run
into is a phantom row,
where you run a select
statement, you don't see a row,
you run a select statement
again, you see the row,
you run it again, you
don't see the row, right?
These kinds of things are happening
because there's multiple
transactions running
on the database the whole time.
And so the job of the database is to try
and isolate our transaction
as much as possible
to give us the illusion
that we're the only user on the system,
because that's gonna allow
us to write correct code.
And because DSQL is slightly
stronger than repeatable read,
that means that there are fewer anomalies.
In fact, DSQL only has one
anomaly called write skew.
And so if anybody would like
to talk about write skew
later in this talk, depending
on how much time we have,
we can do that.
- Yep.
- Okay,
so what I wanna do right now
is start to take this
Lambda function that we have
and turn it into a little
banking application.
- [Raluca] I'm just gonna add one thing
to what Marc just mentioned.
Strong snapshot isolation in DSQL
means we have this property
of being strongly consistent.
So whatever you write
will be immediately seen
by all the other places you read from.
So you don't have to worry
about routing your query
to a specific reader or
to a specific endpoint
because wherever you read from,
you're gonna immediately
see what has been written.
And that is a strong consistency
as opposed to eventual consistency,
which some other database
flavors would offer.
So that's strong snapshot isolation.
And then there's two more
things, we call transactions ACID
because they're atomic,
consistent, insulate, and durable.
And I'm gonna quickly touch on consistency
while Marc is doing all the coding there.
That means you don't get
these phantom money transfer
where you've sent, you see
the money in one account,
you don't see it in the other.
Everything stays consistent.
The database moves from
one valid state to another
in a consistent mode.
And then you have durability,
which means the database will recover,
in case of errors, for you.
So once you've acknowledged
that a write has been
made to the database,
you'll always continue to
see that data persisted
in the database.
You don't have to worry about
machine restarts or failures.
All right, let's see, what are we doing?
- [Marc] I am doing ceremony,
so this is kind of a little boring code,
but I wanted to, you know,
if we have time later on in this talk,
we can maybe move to
like a bit of a higher-level
abstraction through an ORM.
But I wanted to take the time
to show you what it looks like
to write these transactions
at a very low level.
So we have our, we sort of
have a try-catch pattern.
And then within the try-catch,
we have a begin and commit, right?
And that's gonna start
our transaction boundary.
And then if anything goes wrong,
we are just gonna throw the error,
and we're gonna have to take care
to return this connection
to the pool, right?
Otherwise, when we run the function again,
we're gonna start to go from
20 available connections to 19
until we eventually have an outage.
And here's our pay state,
here's our pay query.
So we are gonna be taking
money out of the account.
And notice how I'm using bind variables
just to make sure that
we don't have a case
of Bobby drop tables going on here.
And this is the payee who's
gonna be receiving money.
And we need to do a
little bit of checks here.
So, what can go wrong? Think
about that for a moment.
- [Raluca] Let me know
if you need me to hand the mic to anyone.
Okay.
(mouse clicks)
- [Person] So the thing
is, let's say we have,
we are running two
transaction, same transactions.
We're drawing the amount
from the bank account.
- [Raluca] Okay.
- [Person] The bank
account has $100 balance.
The transaction is also doing the same,
like it's withdrawing $100,
because both the transactions
running in parallel.
How are you gonna handle that situation?
- [Raluca] That's an
excellent question. Thank you.
(chuckles) Because it segues
into what I wanted to
talk to you next about,
which is how theses DSQL
handles concurrency control.
So, we do optimistic concurrency control,
which means when two transactions
try to update the same row,
they will both be allowed to try.
And then the first transaction
to issue the commit will win,
and the second transaction
will have to retry.
And that retry logic needs to be embedded
in the application code.
And so the ideal design
pattern is idempotent
so that transactions can
just retry on failure
and they don't need to
embed any business logic.
So that's optimistic concurrency control.
And if you were to use the opposite,
which is pessimistic concurrency control,
this used to be my nightmare
as an Oracle EBA. (chuckles)
So you'd get all these sessions,
all the transactions lining
up, waiting for a row lock,
I think it was called.
The wait event was in queue transaction,
row lock contention, something like that.
And Postgres would be a lock relation.
So what happens there
is the first transaction trying
to grab, to update the row,
grab the lock on that row,
and then the subsequent ones
will just line up and say,
"I want to update that row,
I want to update that row."
And eventually, either the
first session needs to be killed
or it just finishes doing the
processing it needed to do.
And then the whole thing unblocks it.
And that particular scenario also requires
an abort and retry logic, except in DSQL,
you just get notified sooner
and you need to retry.
- Okay.
- [Person] So the
transaction on the that's....
That's fine, I can, so the transaction,
the first transaction, basically,
when it acquires a lock on the row?
- [Raluca] Yeah.
- [Person] The row will be released
only when the commit happens?
- There's no lock.
In DSQL?
(person faintly speaks)
Pardon?
(person faintly speaking)
- [Person] The variables are rolling out.
- [Raluca] Marc, your variables
are all wrong.
- They are?
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Thank you.
- [Person] On the involvement,
you said balance is one, ID is two.
- [Marc] Ah, thank you so much.
You probably just saved us an hour.
So the release is not gonna-
- [Raluca] There's no
lock, it's lock-free.
There is no lock in this SQL.
- Oh, okay.
- So that's why
we can also support higher
transaction throughput
because you don't have to
wait for another transaction.
There's no coordination there.
Everybody who wants to update
will just issue the update,
and then the first one
to have to commit wins.
And then the other ones
get serialization error.
It's Postgres error, code 40001.
- [Marc] Hm.
- [Raluca] Oh, and by the way, (chuckles)
I have to tell you this,
if you go to the AWS booth
in the expo in the Venetian,
and they ask you the one unique thing
you've learned from this session,
and you tell them about
serialization error 40001,
they will hand you a
hoodie, an AWS hoodie,
and a sticker, a TC code sticker.
Do you have more questions?
I have one more.
- No, I'm good.
- [Raluca] Thank you.
- Yeah, we're actually go
look right at conflicts
in a moment,
because as soon as we start
to run this a bunch of times,
we're gonna see exactly
your question in action.
So let's see if we can invoke this.
- [Raluca] Marc, I have one
more question. Can I take it?
- [Marc] Oh yeah, let's take that.
- [Person] It's actually not a question.
A little bit of a contrarian
comment, if I may?
- [Raluca] Okay.
- [Person] And don't get
me wrong, I love DSQL,
and I think it's a marvel of engineering
and brings a lot of value.
I was just, wanna say
that I'm not totally sold
on that the optimistic
locking approach used here
is straightaway better
than classical Postgres,
because having to do
idempotency puts a burden
on the developer,
that if you run on repeatable
read committed mode,
which is the usual for Postgres,
and most applications are fine with that,
it's an extra burden,
adds friction on the
application developer side.
And having to have
retries can also at point
also hamper performance,
because you're doing retries
versus just waiting a little
bit for a lock to be acquired.
So just this comment is not,
it's something that makes sense,
and it's an acceptable compromise,
but still a compromise.
I don't think it's just
straight out better.
- [Raluca] Wait, we call
it a trade off. (chuckles)
It is what you need to obtain
a higher throughput, right?
- [Marc] So, we're gonna actually
dig into OCC in a minute.
So, your two points, I think there's,
Is it better than
Postgres? Is it ergonomic?
And what performance?
Let's make sure we cover
all three of those.
So our function works,
we're returning the balance
using the Postgres returning syntax.
And so if we run a bunch of times,
we can see our money going down.
So I'm gonna quickly
run this setup script,
and then we can, we have 1,000 accounts,
and then we can do,
let's see if I remember where we are now.
Are we on chapter two? I think so, maybe.
Okay, so this is gonna open
up to 1,000 requests in parallel,
and it's gonna call that function.
And every time it calls that function,
it's gonna say, "Pick a random account,
a random payer, a random
payee, move some money around."
And then this is gonna keep
track of the errors we get back.
And you'll see that we're
getting change conflicts
with another transaction, right?
And so the reason this is important
from a correctness point of view
is that we are running
all of these checks here.
Like, does the payer exist?
Does the payee exist?
Do I have enough money?
And because we have this
concurrency going on,
DSQL is detecting, and it's
detecting here on line 43,
that somebody else has
mucked with the data
that you've been working with, right?
And so you need to try again.
And the way we do that
is we're gonna handle this
error code and just try again.
So we'll say "while true,"
and then I need to indent everything.
(mouse clicking)
And then in our catch block,
this gets a a little funky in TypeScript
because of error handing,
but what we're gonna say is if
the error is not a PG error,
(keyboard clicking)
something else has just gone wrong.
Then we're gonna run this old code.
(mouse clicking)
Otherwise, we're gonna take
a look at the error code.
So this function here just lets us
like get some type of
information out of the error.
(mouse clicking)
We can just run continue,
and then we'll have a to-do over here.
Now it's kind of important,
I've made this bug a bunch of times,
to make sure that we are
grabbing a new connection
outta the pool inside this loop over here.
(mouse clicking)
Okay, and I'm gonna do a
little bit more decoration here
just so we can keep track of our retries.
So we'll say retry is a number.
(keyboard clicking)
That's a typo.
And we'll say duration is a number too.
And then at the start here,
we'll take the current time.
(keyboard clicking)
And then down here we
will return the duration.
(keyboard clicking)
We're gonna do that down here, too,
for a reason that we become apparent.
Okay, and then we need to
return retries too, right?
- [Raluca] Right, so we
just have some telemetry
around the OCC retries.
To your point, you can exactly quantify
what your hotspots are,
how many times you have to retry
if the application
tends to have these hot,
deadlocks, and so on, so.
And if you do want, for example,
not to have all the
sessions retry at once,
then you would add some
exponential back off and retries
and things like that.
But in this case, I don't
think that's gonna be required
in this simple application.
(keyboard clicking)
- [Person] Just-
- [Raluca] Hold on, I want
everybody to hear what you say.
Just hold on.
- [Person] Just if I may.
Absolutely, I like the
word that it's a trade off.
That's exactly what it is.
That's why I just wanna make sure
that it's not presented
as a best solution,
because again, if I run, for example,
read committed mode
using regular Postgres,
I will not need to do this while true loop
and check for the errors
and handle the retries.
I'm not saying this is better or worse,
it's again a trade off,
but here you're forced
versus not being forced,
and therefore, it's a compromise, yeah.
- [Raluca] Thanks. Does anybody
have any other questions?
Okay.
- [Marc] Okay, so this code
is actually still wrong,
and the reason is we
need to handle our errors
a little bit better over here,
but we'll see what happens when we run it.
So adding this retry
loop is work for sure.
You know, I've gone a
little bit above and beyond
in terms of adding telemetry,
because I want you to
see when we run this code
what the error rate is, right?
And it's gonna be really
bad, (chuckles) right?
And the reason it's really bad
is that we only have
1,000 accounts, right?
We're running at 1,000
requests per second.
And so the chance
of there being two concurrent
requests of the conflict
is gonna be pretty high.
(computer chiming)
(mouse clicking)
Timeout exceeded. (sighs)
I think I'm leaking connection somewhere.
Okay, gimme a moment to debug.
- [Raluca] I'm happy to take
more questions in the meantime.
I saw that hand first.
I'll go up there first.
- [Person] Thank you.
Yeah, I was just wondering
what the problem was with,
like you mentioned you had to
push the client acquisition
inside the like retry loop.
What's the issue you run
into if you don't do that?
- [Marc] Yeah, that's a great question.
(mouse clicking)
Gimme a sec, I can't
do two things at once.
Okay, so the reason we had a leak here
is that I wasn't returning
the connection to the pool.
The reason we wanna do that is,
depending on how much
time we get here today,
I wanna show you just how you can recover
from other kinds of errors in DSQL, right?
For example, when you're
running on a single node system,
what happens if your primary fails?
Right, like you have to
learn about the new primary,
you have to shift your connections open.
And so in DSQL, because
you're a distributed system,
each of your connections
is actually running
on a different machine somewhere.
And so when something goes wrong,
you're gonna lose just a fraction
of your healthy connections,
depending on like what failed.
And so it's really important
that your application can
take advantage of that
and get it, grab a new
connection and keep going.
And so the simplest way to do that
is to simply grab a
connection out of the pool
when you retry, right?
Because if anything goes wrong,
and then you can change that
catch handler to simply say,
"Hey, if any of these, you know,
if any of these conditions happen,
just grab a new connection and try again."
- [Raluca] We have one more question here,
and then I'll come there.
- [Person] Do we have to
to pay for each connection?
So if I open 1,000 connection,
do I have to pay something
if I don't run any query?
- [Marc] No.
So the question is, how do
you pay for connections?
The answer is connections
are free, with an asterisk.
And the asterisk is that
opening a connection
does a small number of reads
because it has to do things
like check your permissions.
Right? But the thing you're
actually paying for is usage.
So you pay for reads and writes.
And so once you've opened a connection,
like you can just leave
it there idle, it's fine.
- Okay.
- Okay,
so we're done with that,
and we'll notice that
our min execution times
are pretty low, but our max
execution times are pretty high.
And the reason for that is we
are doing a bunch of retries.
Okay-
- [Raluca] I have more question.
- [Marc] So what I'm gonna do now
is actually load this
system up a little bit more.
And what this script is gonna do
is just dump in a million accounts.
And while we do that,
we're gonna quickly add another table,
which is our transaction log table.
- [Raluca] Marc, I have one more question.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
You, yeah.
- [Person] I know in the DSQL launch
there was a few unsupported features,
like foreign keys, partition sequences.
Are things like that planned
to be added in the future,
or is it like the distributed
nature kind of makes it
so they'd be not able to be implemented?
Did I phrase that, I hope
I phrased that correctly.
- [Raluca] Yeah, so foreign
keys are on the roadmap.
We do plan to be closing that gap
with the Postgres competitive.
One more question here?
Did you have one more question, or?
Oh, I missed, oh, sorry.
- [Person] So in a distributed
database kind of thing,
how do you manage, because you mentioned
that right consistencies are
maintained in an optimized way,
and once you get a confirmation
about a right commit,
it'll be read across the
cluster in the same way.
But if somebody reads a transaction
which is returned in somewhere else,
does it, the decision needs to wait,
how does it get the committed
block from the storage?
Because storage is being
shared, not the data.
So, how does that happen?
- [Marc] Yeah, so this is the reason
that we do optimistic concurrency
control in the system,
right?
Because there's really two ways to do it.
with pessimistic currency control,
as soon as you do anything in the system,
you have to go and sort
of like put a lock there,
saying like, "Hey, I'm busy here," right?
And that would require us pushing down
that locking information somewhere, right?
With optimistic concurrency
control, we don't do that.
We just do our work
completely independent of everybody else.
And then when we commit,
the commit's written to a single place.
And that single place looks at
everything that you're doing,
and it checks if it's been,
if somebody else has done something
that interferes with it, right?
- [Person] So you need to check, right,
if somebody else made a
transaction on the block
that somebody else is interested in?
- [Marc] Right, and so
it looks at the changes
that you're making.
So in this case, because
both transactions are reading
and writing the payer and the payee id,
so if we have one transaction
that is one, two, three, right,
that's account one and account three,
and the other one is account
three and account five,
then because both of them
have three in their right set,
when they get to the point of commit,
that's when the system,
called the adjudicator,
is gonna look at that and say,
"Only one of these can go through,
and the other one has to retry."
And so there's like no,
there's nothing happening at
the storage layer to do this.
It's all happening at the commit layer.
- [Person] Okay, so do you
have a memory share concept
between the cluster also?
- [Marc] Everything is
just fully independent.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
Okay, so we have a table
of transactions now,
and all this is is a record
of everything we've done in the system.
And there's two columns
that are being automatically
generated by the database.
The first one is the ID, which is a UUID
And the reason we wanna use a UUID here
is for the same reason
that you would want to use
one in DynamoDB, right?
That's gonna just give you
the best possible fan out,
which is maybe a different
philosophy than you would have
on a instance-based Postgres system
where you want to do
everything sequentially
to get the best IO.
Right, in DSQL is just
way better to go wide.
And then the last column creates
it out as just a timestamp.
And so what we're gonna do in our function
is just populate this table.
(keyboard clicking)
See if I get this wrong
again. Up here first.
Okay.
- [Raluca] Did you assign the the role to-
- [Marc] Did I do that?
- I don't-
- Maybe.
- [Raluca] I missed it.
(Marc chuckling)
Good.
- [Marc] Thank you for checking me.
Okay, so what I wanna show you now is,
this table's gonna start
to fill up rapidly, right,
when we start to run at scale.
And we're gonna want to
be able to query that.
So imagine this is a real application.
Our customer's going to our page
and they're clicking on their homepage,
and they wanna see what
transactions that they've run.
And so we're gonna wanna run a query,
"select * from transactions,"
where we can pick out for this account,
where payee ID equals that number.
And then we see our log, right?
And if we run this a few more times,
we should see more rows.
(mouse clicking)
There we go. Okay, the RNG was on my side.
But I wanna show you quickly
how to think about performance here.
So if we do "explain select from account,"
you'll see that we're doing
a full scan on this table,
right, because there aren't any indexes.
And what we can do here is,
I'm actually gonna use "explain analyze,"
which is gonna give us a
little bit more information,
'cause this actually runs a query.
So we can say "create index,"
I'm intentionally getting
this wrong for a moment,
on "transactions, payer ID,
on transactions, payer ID,"
and I'm an insert, put "created
at" in here, for a reason.
And we get an error, "unsupported mode."
And you'll see that we
have to use the syntax
called "create index ASYMC."
And the reason we do this in
DSQL is because in Postgres,
when you create an index, by default,
you're gonna be taking a lock on the table
so nobody else can
record any transactions.
Because the system needs to go row by row
and make sure that it's
building the index correctly.
Now, Postgres has an alternative syntax
called "create index concurrently."
That does less locking, but
it still does some locking
because it has to wait for
this sort of quiescent phase
before it can start.
And it also has to scan the table twice,
which can be very expensive
and cause performance impact.
And there's another small issue
with create index concurrently,
which is that there's no
way to track it, right?
And so when we were thinking
about building the system,
we wanted to solve all these problems
and create index ASYMC gives you a job ID
that you can wait for.
So if we do "call sys.wait for job"
and put this ID in here, it
should say it's succeeded.
And you can actually take
a look at all of the jobs
that the system has been running
by digging into this table,
and you'll notice that
there's this index build
that we just did here.
But there's also these
analyze jobs, right?
Because the system
is constantly looking
at stats in your tables
to make sure that it's
building the right query plans.
But if we go and run our query gain,
you'll notice that it's still
doing a full scan, right?
And this is just a little
gotcha for you to keep in mind.
Actually, I probably picked
the wrong field here.
Okay, we're using our index here,
but if we picked a different ID,
maybe one with fewer transactions,
or if we had a smaller table,
you may still see a full scan,
because the query plan is
actually free to choose, right?
It can say, "Hey, should
I scan this whole table?"
If there's only 10 rows in it,
then it might just scan the whole table.
Or it's gonna take a look
at those analyzed jobs
that are running,
it's gonna take a look at
the indexes that are running
and pick an efficient query plan for you.
This may look very intimidating.
If you're not used to reading query plans,
just dump it in your favorite AI tool,
and we'll do like a really good job
telling you what's going on here.
But I wanna quickly call
out a couple of things here.
This is using an index,
and there is no sorting.
And if we do something like
"order by created at descending,"
you'll see that there's still no sorting,
just your eyes scan
for memory, quick sort,
anything like that, not in that list.
Because we actually put the
timestamp in the index, right?
So this is gonna allow like the database
to traverse the data in the right order.
And what's already cool
about create index ASYMC,
'cause you can do this
fully online at, you know,
any scale you want, and
there's never any blocking,
and there's never gonna
be any performance impact,
because it's built
completely asynchronously
in the background using dedicated
resources for your index.
Now with that said,
I wanna show you how we can
scale this application out.
So this could get a little messy because,
you know, demo gods.
So let's take a run.
So this tool,
(Raluca chuckles)
(keyboard clicking)
this is sustained load generator,
and we're gonna tell it
how many accounts there are
in the system.
There is a million.
And then we're gonna give each host
a target number of
transactions per second.
And what they're gonna do
is you'll notice this little
inflight counter over here,
they're gonna continue to
open batches of connections
until this number on the bottom
left gets to their target.
And so with this running,
we have four machines driving 4,000 TPS.
And if we jump over here, we can do,
(keyboard clicking)
and this is actually gonna go row by row
and count every transaction we have.
And if I do this again,
it's gonna be even slower.
(chuckles) It's gonna go row
by row with even more data.
But this number should start ticking up.
Now,
(keyboard clicking)
that didn't fail, so let's
go a little bit higher.
At this number, I should
hit the account quota
for Lambda, (chuckles)
right, on my system.
But pay attention to these numbers here,
error and OCC.
We're not getting any errors,
and we're not getting any OCC errors.
And the reason for that
is by sort of cheating with
the number of accounts, right,
We've created more right keys.
And so the probability
of any of these transactions
conflicting is low.
Now this is a obviously a
little contrived example.
I didn't wanna spend too much of this talk
getting into like some kind of like
really complex real-world schema,
but the takeaway for you
is to think about designing
your app and schemas
so that you don't have what
we call hot-for-write keys.
Right?
Okay, while that runs, let's
take a quick look at pricing.
If we jump on over to our cluster-
- [Raluca] Can I just
grab everyone's attention
to highlight that we went
from 1,000 concurrency to,
what was it, 10,000?
How much did you put in the system?
- [Marc] Yeah, we're running
at about 10,000 TPS right now.
- [Raluca] And we didn't need
to provision higher instances
or more parameter groups
with a higher number of connections
allowed, or any of that.
So, that's another nice thing
to learn to bear in mind.
- [Marc] Yeah.
Nothing to patch, nothing
to scale. (chuckles)
Just send traffic at the
system, it scales for you.
And if you're using something
like Lambda that can scale,
then you also don't have
to worry about the compute.
So this is the, so we're
on the cluster page,
I've clicked on metrics,
I clicked on usage,
and you'll see that there are,
there's really two
metrics for you to track.
There is total DPU. DPU is a
distributed processing unit.
And this is like a pay per use metric.
If you're used to DynamoDB, in
DynamoDB, you pay for rights,
and you pay for reads,
and you pay for storage.
And DSQL has all three of these units too,
but it also has an additional
one which is called compute.
And this is like Lambda, you're
paying for compute seconds
because we're a SQL engine, right?
And so you can run these complex queries
that are doing joins, that
can be doing aggregates,
you can do Fibonacci in it.
And so there needs to be
some way to track that usage.
DPUs are, you can monitor
them with CloudWatch.
I've also built a little tool
where if we can take this cluster ID,
make sure I'm in the right place,
we can paste it in here.
And that's gonna go fetch
those CloudWatch metrics,
just sum up all of the data points.
Run it through our pricing calculator,
and you'll see that we spent $2 on DSQL.
If I stop this load and
we wait a few minutes,
and we run this again, it'll
still be $2, (chuckles) right?
If we wait five minutes
and leave the load running,
it'll eventually take up to $3 or $4.
I've run this workload for,
you know, 20, 30 minutes,
and I came back and it's
running at a million TPS,
and I spend $10.
So this is one of the really
cool things about DSQLs,
that not only are you not
having to provision hardware,
but the database just out of the box
is gonna give you this ability to scale up
and pay only for what you're
using in that moment, right?
So if this load stops,
that's it, you're done.
Frozen in time.
The thing that you're gonna
continue to pay for is storage.
Okay, I think we have five minutes left,
so we should probably wrap it up
and take any final questions.
- [Raluca] I have a ten-second comments,
and then the rest of questions,
if there are more, we can-
- [Marc] I'll be hanging
around outside afterwards.
- [Raluca] Thanks, everyone.
- Please remember to fill in
the survey for the session.